I really really important about supply
and demand and the number one thing
right now that is in short supply is us
caring about each other or having time
for each other because we all got very
busy in a 24/7 365 world I really really
do believe that that is now the most
valuable thing in the world and the
differentiator and I in a world where we
have so many smart people with all the
companies that have logos up right now
that are very smart about customer
acquisition through retargeted banner
ads and all the other funnels that you
think about how to get I think we're all
thinking way too much about hunting and
we all need to start thinking a lot more
about farming retention is a great way
to build businesses too and I think most
of us suck at it in this world because a
lot of it is very script based
analytical and very smart but I'm
telling you the EQ of our collective
Silicon Alley Silicon Valley I was in
Denver the mayor said that he wants to
call it silicon Mountain what the [ __ ]
but okay cool you know whatever we call
it whatever we call it everybody in this
room and our space needs to start
thinking about retention and farming a
lot more than hunting and acquisition
because I think it's going to in a world
where acquisition is becoming a
commodity because there's so many smart
people doing it it's gonna shift the
tide so I highly highly implore people
to start putting more effort to the
persons and the people that actually
impact their business